[Musique]
bonsoir nos amis
auxquels voyage
allons-nous nours réveille-toi nous
sommes arrivés en bus au but mais oui
nous sommes arrivés chez nicolas et
pimprenelle monsieur re le ch recrutent
ou lolo le pauvre thomas ma petite heure
bon le choc la bougeotte
europe au groupe pro au
cours de bourse gourmand aux propos
s'ils n'avaient pas mangé temps de
gâteaux au mariage de son cousin hans il
ne serait pas malade
votre pauvre petit nounours est infime
la dre si vous trouvez qu'est ce moment
mais oui c'est était
prévu qu'ils n'avaient pas mangé trop de
gâteaux par l eau ne me parlez plus de
cas
[Musique]
alors cassé toi et montre de ce que tu
ne viens apporter
[Musique]
romanel tout d'abord merci pour le beau
chapeau que vous m'avez prêté il a eu
beaucoup de succès ces chapeaux d'abbas
à un copain papin voilà aussi le noeud
papillon
mais voici un porte-bonheur un morceau
de voile blanc de la marine
et voilà pour mes amis
un chalet boîte à musique
jamais qu'il est joli tout mon argent
eux pas su écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a certes une hausse des neiges ou en
gros noms au doucement je me sente si
fatigué
ma bouillotte
retombé
mais voilà au maine où tu veux pas
garder une voiture est justement comme
une grenade
ma bouche auto
[Musique]
auto de combourg mans et de matu sa
grille
[Musique]
demain
bonne nuit mais au fond
allez vite vous allez encore
faire plus
[Musique]
alors nounours comment te sens-tu mieux
lourd beaucoup mieux pas trop je suis
presque au curry allons vite nous
coucher comme ça demain je serai
entièrement guéri en route bonne nuit
les enfants adam un fêtes de bourg
oh
[Musique]
e